[Music]
stars with a much larger mass than our
Sun burn out after just a few million
years in a gigantic explosion known as a
supernova moving at the speed of light
millions of tons of plasma neutrinos and
a whole lot of light are ejected from
this explosion but there's something
left behind what exactly is this thing
and what would happen if our Sun was one
of them this is what if and here's what
would happen if the Sun became a neutron
star a neutron star is one of the
strangest things in our universe it's
dimensions are pretty crazy but bear
with us the star is only 20 kilometers
across that's smaller than most cities
not only that but the sheer density of
this relatively tiny star is also
bizarre a single cubic centimeter of a
neutron star weighs 400 million tons but
what exactly does that mean
to put it in perspective imagine every
single vehicle in the United States
being crushed up into just a single
sugar cube now imagine millions of those
coming together and that's a neutron
star with dimensions like this there
would be some pretty significant
implications for us if our Sun was
suddenly replaced by one let's get this
straight
our Sun will never become a neutron star
why because neutron stars are born from
Suns that are 10 to 20 times the size of
ours in five billion years our Sun will
become a red giant and then eventually a
cold dwarf which is similar to a neutron
star just much larger and much less
dense but forget about all that this is
what if after all so what if well a
neutron star replacing our Sun would be
pretty dangerous to say the least a
neutron stars gravitational force would
be 2 billion times stronger than Earth's
this means that pretty quickly every
single planet in our solar system would
be pulled towards the start and be
destroyed and it wouldn't stop there a
neutron star rotates incredibly fast
whereas our Sun rotates once every 27
days or so a neutron star rotates over
700 times every second
this means the star would be whirling
through space at one-fifth the speed of
light after thousands of years many
neutron stars begin to slow down and
fizzle out but that doesn't always
happen sometimes a neutron star meets
another star the neutron star will begin
to orbit the fully formed Sun and will
feed off its atmosphere until it
eventually collapses in on itself and
becomes a black hole if you happen to be
in another galaxy at the time you'd see
the neutron star as a flashing light
also known as a pulsar discovered in
1967 by astrophysicist Jocelyn Bell
pulsars are caused by a neutron stars
magnetic field which - no one's surprise
is incredibly strong but let's hope this
neutron star isn't a magnetar what's a
magnet are you asked it's an even
stronger and rarer type of neutron star
a neutron stars magnetic field may be
incredibly strong but a magnet arz
magnetic field is 1,000 times more
powerful yeah we weren't kidding about
these numbers being a little ridiculous
the crust of this star is under a
massive amount of strain if it happens
to move at all it creates a starquake
yeah that might sound like a super cool
sounding word but don't let it fool you
these things are scary the crust of the
star would erupt in a massive explosion
causing its magnetic field to react this
would create a massive solar storm that
travels across the entire galaxy and it
wouldn't just be any solar storm it
would
be trillions of times stronger than
anything the Sun could produce what
would happen if the earth got hit by
this massive solar storm well that
sounds like a question for another
what-if
you